What you could get out of that is an automatic cause-effect chain
isolating the causes for different places during the program execution.
For instance, at the beginning s had a value of double quote and <,
then c became a double quote again are well-defined in the failing room,
then quote became true, and then out became <, which caused this version to fail.
This cause-effect chain is what you get when you apply delta debugging
on state differences at various places during the execution.
In producing such a cause-effect chain automatically is your homework.
This is a very cool outcome but is also a pretty tricky homework.
In particular, setting variables while the program is executing
is a feature that's very rarely used, very rarely tested, and therefore full of surprises.
On the web page, you will find a number of hints and code templates
that help you in accomplishing this task.
Having such a cause-effect chain and getting it automatically
sounds like a great promise for debugging
In particular because it very neatly tells you the story of how the failure came to be.
In particular the relationship of c having a double quote and then the quote variable becoming true
points you directly to the condition, which is at fault at this point.
It should--oh, sorry.
This is already the closest to a fully automatic debugging tool we can get at this point.
However, it is worth to very much consider the limitations.
First and foremost you need to similar runs.
The higher the similarity, the higher the chances of finding a small set of failure-inducing differences.
Even in our homework implementation, there is many things we don't handle.
We'll only handle scalar values and strings.
We won't go into details of how to find differences between say, this or dictionaries
or graph structures, and finally, all of these are still very experimental,
but the fact that it's experimental calls for many ways to extend this,
and this again can be part of your homework.
Again, on the web page, you will find a number of ways of how to further expand this.
So go and build fully automatic debugging for Python programs. Enjoy.